Bin's good morning how are you
good morning doing well I'm kind of
jealous with the steak and eggs
what's a bacon and yeah no sounds good
right now
blob wins Weinstein very good I know
when's the last time you were in snow
two days ago it snow here two days ago
is still here in missions yeah did
people frat life not like what you're
dealing with no no not at all but
they're you know they're upset they're
like you know this is this is ridiculous
for it's a snow here in Memphis right
about now but I guess is that was that
was the last dump we get and we go from
there now it's nothing like what you're
dealing with of course do you feel out
of bracket not yet as fun you say that
them was one scene right in front of me
I'm trying to not be as biased as one
would think could you ever try to fill
this out honestly could you ever pick
dupe to go further than North Carolina
oh we lie yeah I'll just curious you
know it is all depend it is the wick
okay if I'm filling out the brackets for
fun not a chance
okay there you go but if you're the
money bracket yeah yeah you know got to
go for the win
what do you remember most about your
college career this is the best time of
the year I think once regular seasons
overs getting into the ACC tournament
you know you're revving up now you rid
of your revving up for for the Big Dance
and we knew that we were we were set to
get there so we just had to get through
the ACC tournament we wanted to win it
every year of course and we knew who we
had to get through that other school you
talked about earlier so we knew playing
clay nucleus is like the final tuneup
for the for the nth other memory it's
not it wasn't as many I mean it's been a
while with those is a plate but it
wasn't as many teams in th I think
they've added what four teams down you
you since my time maybe she maybe more
than that
but it's the best time of year and I
think people who aren't big basketball
fans look forward to playoffs times in
the NBA and it looks forward to the
tournament time in in college and gotten
better yeah I in you and Antoine Jameson
on that Carolina team
how did Carolina get right like what was
who finished runner-up for you well the
final four schools are about this
Florida Florida State rival and Duke and
Carolina rivals so they said it just
made it tough but I mean at the end of
the day what I was looking for I mean
they're all they all had the qualities
and qualities I'm looking for but I
didn't say I mean you walk it's being
done it's just hard to say no to that
opportunity coach Smith is the very
convincing man he was used for what I
was looking for as a student-athlete
as far as she said he's I come from a
family of educators my mom my entire
family are all educators for that way
you know they're all teachers of some
sort and you know that was important not
only to compete with my family as well
so he really stressed that he really
parked on us as I'm in college I mean he
Harvin is knowing our teachers by their
first name not just the last name
sitting in the first Eros little thing
that probably hmm as a student or have
to say athlete generally stuff you don't
like you know you like to sit out of the
way and just kind of do your thing and
be done with it but he he required that
and they made sure that we were doing so
and he would pull you in and say okay so
what's your Shh find pieces first name
and you like yeah I expect you know that
the next two days so little things like
that he just taught us responsibility
and he's taking on and on our careers in
our lives though I mean it would be a
great conversation leading up into my
decision and it just felt right you know
you wake up in the morning he's like you
know what that's that's where I supposed
to be and that's where that's what
happened if we had a 40 and over dunk
contest I'm winning you are yeah my
competitive nature would definitely
shine through I mean I know this anomaly
is there anybody on
face of the earth use forty years of age
or older who could who could jump where
you jump I'm sure I'm sure there is uh
you know it's just I'm forcing us to
still play the game where I'm I mean
basketball shake maybe you know someone
else at that age probably would have to
get in shape for a while so there's my
advantage right there
how many dunks do you have this season
do you know oh man probably not just a
handful and I tell you I it sometimes
I'll get to the basket and I'll Drive it
in my mind it sounds like a great idea
and then you get a liar one everybody
wants to see the dump it's like okay you
know you have I have these I have all
these questions these quick questions
that you know that I have in my head
while this happens okay okay if we do
this it's great for everyone else but
how would you feel when you land on the
floor you know it's it's not the takeoff
I always say it's the landing you know
some days I'm willing to you know to
deal with the landing and some days oh
my gosh just lay it up or shoot the
floater a runner or whatever and you
know something like this why he does
back I knew you would add uncle yep I
don't have to deal with 40 years of old
hook landing on the ground now so that's
kind of the dilemma I face in some days
like lately I've just said what the heck
go for it is not so good and I'm all for
landing
he's been Shekar Turley Memphis
Grizzlies guard can you are you the best
dunker on the teams - oh man oh no I
tell you what
juh michael green is very capable um
they're to be interesting I mean I okay
Brandon Reich is a dunker you know but
he's not a dunk contest Duncan so as my
competition in my opinion would probably
be to Michael green right now but do
these kids know how bright you were
Vince I mean they know that there's
YouTube out there sure yeah I think so
well because we date
because of YouTube and social media hit
pass through with guys like me I saw the
video where life and people and life
talk about it you know for me it is it
gets good for me I tell you that you
know you're in each unit see what 19
years now is 40 years old you're playing
and it's like Twilight now it's like see
that stuff this Rachel filters like you
know what I some day when I see it I
watch them out in space you know what I
could feel good really you can't jump or
resolve you can't expel where in the
world you can't jump over seven footer
right that attempt right now would be an
awful charge what a notice where the
coach to take me out a game like what
are you doing okay did you ever talk to
Frederic vise after you dunked over him
we'd never know the the only
conversation we had we played France in
the final game in the tenth in the gold
medal game and the same type of
situation has been where we're on that
same left side of the block I go and
this column actually tried to jump over
him he fouled me not to be in the first
row on to the cameraman and all that I
get up and I looked at him he kind of
smiled and I kind of start up it I
understand yeah I understand I
understand it pops out and I'm okay with
it you know I would do the same thing so
and that's probably the only
conversation we've actually had face to
face I've never run across some sense
wouldn't that be a great 34 30 and just
called it the doubt via and odd or get
you Chell via get you two back together
all those that were there everybody who
watched it and just had my Bobby with
well be really weird that we know think
about it think about if we both just
aside this tattoo of a sickness who
stalks her yeah well you what do I say
uh well you know fact is that I'm sorry
I don't I don't know what to say I would
be uh what he said you really hurt my
feelings and it did I say I'm sorry so I
don't know okay okay we Vince all
moderated shall all be the one that
starts the conversation somebody has to
fill out over the LOB and I'll go from
there yes yet I'll set you up I'll be
Stockton you'll be
loan and no no no I'll deliver yeah we
have a poll question today Paulie what
is the full question here for Vince we
basically asked our listeners with whose
life would you rather have billionaire
multi time billionaire Warren Buffett or
the great one of the greatest dunkers of
all time Vince Carter who now Buffett's
were anybody how many billions you think
yeah that's yeah there you go how many
billion he's got 60 billion Vince would
you rather have Mondrian I was good
enough woody well ask Michael Jordan
would you would you trade with Michael
Jordan Warren Buffett or Michael Jordan
ooh well I mean I'm gonna say this and
some some people just up to sports side
of me I would definitely trade with
Michael George because to be a
billionaire to own a team and still be a
part of the basketball world and the
action is where's that 100 did you see
this little quote by Alonzo balls dad
you familiar with Lanza ball and you
shall like I'm familiar okay and now his
his dad has come out and said back in
the day huh he would be Jordan one on
one yeah I'm yeah I heard about it what
do you think I cringed friends I mean
big in I've never seen them play you
know the stats of course you know with
social media hawkers of course they go
publicly it I mean Michael doing was a
bad man plain and simple it was a bad
man that I just take you know why why
would you even even even if you did why
you know particularly in my opinion if
you're going out for this billion
dollars for your kid yeah that's not
something I say because now you've
definitely caught cut off one Soukup in
my approvers Nike Jordan yeah yes
probably it probably Nike all together
yet you know cuz you know they're gonna
support MJ and you know and maybe maybe
it doesn't but it it might be my game
plan and if I probably say that I
wouldn't oh one thing I wouldn't have
said before is you know anything about
anything bad
while Michael Jordan at all do you think
he's helping her around time but you
know but do you think that that
Lunchables dad is helping or hurting his
kids we all probably see it as he's
hurting these kids but in his he may see
it different so it's hard for us to to
really say hard for me to really say I
personally would tell my my dad hey hey
let's just lay low for a while into it
you know Josh cut time gets around and
all this stuff so I personally as the
son wouldn't want that to happen you
know I but I that's my approach I like
to lay low I me hey he's marketing his
kids yeah courted him out there he's
making sure regardless of if you like
him or not you're gonna know who he and
his three kids are so that's the
strategy he wants to go for and you know
I think he's he's successful is because
we're having the conversation as soon as
I said what's the next thing we talk
about all of these things that he said
so whether or not he's the villain on
his tours a hero or the smart strategy
strategist with this he's he's getting
some goal is accomplished just my god
definitely wouldn't I leave Michael
Jordan lone does Michael Jordan think he
could beat you right now of course he
does
this is Michael Jordan and the way he
thinks absolutely
could he I wouldn't let him I can't I
can't let him I'm gonna put up a fight
for sure are you afraid to say that
Jordan couldn't beat you because you
know Mike is so competitive that he
would I know I know Mike and I know how
competitive he is and I know if if it's
a one-on-one with no referee I've played
against them in that setting before and
I know very little foul call he won't
allow very many foul call against him
which is not right it's just all right
but you you could beat Jordan one-on-one
now I think I can just as of right now
today this week yeah III think though
because I'm playing he's not playing I
def
have to use that to my advantage the
longer the game plays out I think it if
we played a three you know it's
different
you played a kid I like my chances all
right I got a shot
how about this both 24 both honking dunk
contest you and Jordan I like me to dunk
on this I just I can't step down from
that one it's a major a player all-time
I give it to Mike but Vince you know
it's interesting even Reggie Miller when
I have him on once a week and Reggie's
about the same age is Mike everybody is
nervous still about saying anything
about Jordan that yeah I agree
like up the leg the Shivering over I
don't want to see my team psycho you
think you could all right so is that I
have that's it exit toe
Congrats on my real night I hope there's
no reason to retire
is there no I don't think so you know I
hear people tell me you're doing this
for what I still love the game I'm still
able to play the game but my body says
it's had enough it's had enough when the
love is gone I'll walk away but you know
I still think I could play this game on
a high level and compete and you know
every opportunity I get to kind of be
the OVC that we know i'ma do it so
you're coming back next year yeah nice
and you can guard LAN out of law hahaha
but don't don't try to guard his dad
because he could Chiron you officer
yeah just follow and put at the
free-throw line why not safe travels
there Congrats again last night
Vincent's always great kept something
thank you always a pleasure man thanks
for inch card Memphis Grizzlies car
coming back next year age 41 they are so
nervous now to say anything about Jordan
now starting still a killer the Dan
Patrick show weekday morning on audience
you